voilà ce qui arrive lorsque moteur
équipée d'airbags et éjecté de sa
motoneige le dos et cervicales
donc si vous avez le casse ça évite le
le coup du lapin le coccyx d'accord et
le thorax évidemment gilet ou blouson se
gonfle instantanément avant la chute au
sol vous avez la cartouche le dispositif
une petite cartouche d'air comprimé qui
se vissent dans la poche
il suffira d'attaché le gilet à la moto
tout le monde voit à chaque fois vous
monter sur la moto vous en cracher le
dispositif l'airbag ne se gonflera qu en
cas d'éjection violente au ce dispositif
intéresse conducteur comme passager
grand public et compétiteurs de tout âge
ça protège bien et en plus à éviter
d'avoir des bestiaux est-ce que c'est
effrayant quand on futé ce qu'on a
besoin d'eux justement d'être un petit
peu plus rassuré encore un super mais en
interne c'est madhi arrivé une fois et
j'aime bien sûr
à montaud la sécurité c'est essentiel
donc on n'a pas de carrosserie donc tout
ce qui peut le protéger
on et prom des preneurs même si
effectivement ça coûte mais bon quand
vous êtes par terre vous êtes bien
content d'avoir investi 400 ou 600 euros
et d'être en un seul morceau
le gouvernement voudrait voir la
généralisation de l'airbag les moto
écoles ont à présent obligation de le
faire porter aux élèves sur la route
les assureurs ont promis des mesures
incitatives sous la chaleur des
tropiques
daniel s'en accommode plutôt bien il est
comme amusant normal puisque il ya des
versions étaient des versions hiver donc
pour la martinique évidemment l'aviation
étaient les plus adaptées il est un peu
plus l'eau mais à la limite une fois
qu'on l'a mis
on roule on ne sent aucune gêne
je suis fervent défenseur du dispositif
fiable je pense tous les professionnels
en que ce soit votre ip ou bien les
professionnels de la moto comme les
gendarmes les policiers qui étaient à
l'importance
du blouson airbag n'est plus à démontrer
en martinique les conducteurs de deux
roues représentent 2 % des usagers de la
route seulement mais 30 % des tués cet
équipement supplémentaire se vend entre
400 et 600 euros